την επιτυχεία τους τη όσον αφογά τη τη δουλειά τούτες επιχειρήσεις του ένας άνθρωπος που
είχε πολύ έτσι κουρτούρπου ενδιαφγον για πολλά πράματα η συλλογή ιγαλική νασκευτίς που εξεκίνης από
τη δεκαϊτία του εξήντα έπεπε να είχες κάποιον όγαμμα για να και να μάρθεις για
να διαλέξεις αυτούς τους πίνακες που εδιάλεξη και νδιαφέγοντα για πάρα πολλάθέματα αγαπούσε πολύ την
οικογένια του και μαλιότην οικοιένεια γενικά την οικογένεια και από τα αδέλφια τούκαι τα ανήψεια
του και κείνο ήταν το κύπριακοστιχείωνουμηίκαι έτσι έχωρες αναμνήσεις πως αντιμετώπιησε όταν η μικρή τότε
φωτεινή δε νομίζομε δεαριστημένοςτο ανακίνωσε ότι θα παντρευτεί των πολύ καδεν ί δεν νομίζω να
ήταν πολύ ευχαριστημένως αλλά αντάξει το το γέκτηκεμεγάλη οικονομικαι επιφανεα τότε του πατέρα σας γι
αυτό σας ρωτησάν μεγάλος ατε νεόρια δηλαδή υπήρχαν κάποια όρια αστό τι θα μπορούσατε να
τους ζητήσετε ναι εμεί εγώ τουλάχιστον και με τη μητέρα μου που είχαμε πάντοτε για
δηλαδήν υπήρχε θέματαχριστούν για να θυμούμε δια λιες ένα πάμα δύο πράματα και τέλειαι δηλαδή
δεν υδεν υπήρχει εκείνον τοότι θέλουμεγάζουμε σήνεσήμέρα ναι ωρισμένα παιδιά δηλαδή αλλά και πάμε στο
άλλο κεφάλεο τα ένει στου τάσουπ αβαδόπουλου πως ήταν η ζωή σας δήπλαστε νασμογάδον ήταν
μια ζωή και και έτσι πολύ παγαπολ διαφέον διότι ότα σως ήταν όπως πολύ μοφωμένο
νδιαφέγονταν για πάγα πολλά θέματα αγαπούσε την